the Atlantic Ocean has long been the
lifeblood of keansburg New Jersey but as
climate change drives rising sea levels
and more severe storms this water it's
increasingly a threat now a new study
suggests that globally the number of
people living on land at risk of coastal
flooding could be three times what was
previously thought here where many lost
everything in superstorm sandy
it's unwelcome news would you move
because of sea level rises I would
definitely I am going to move because of
sea level rises and at some point when
my life is in a better position the
ocean no no mother nature winds and the
effect of that my brother was telling me
about an article in the paper that said
in 30 years he's serving Union Beach
those towns aren't going to be here
anymore and I find that sad I kid around
and I say that and I'll have oceanfront
property you know but it's really a sad
thought that would be a worst-case
scenario but not impossible to come up
with these predictions scientists have
used a new digital model to more
accurately measure ground elevations and
while it is bad news for places like
keansburg the worst impacts are going to
be felt in other parts of the world in
areas that are less developed and
already more vulnerable to the effects
of climate change
that includes countries like Bangladesh
and Vietnam as well as China and India
the study says that by 2050 150 million
people could find themselves living on
land below the high-tide mark and 300
million others could be living in places
affected by coastal flooding at least
once a year
that's even if we reduce carbon
emissions in line with the Paris
agreement it could be much worse by the
end of the century if emissions remain
unchecked with rising seas threatening
as many as six hundred and forty million
people what concerns me most from this
research is I think of the political
instability that has visited on Europe
over the last five years out of
migration pressures from Syria and
Africa the refugees and then I think
that that number of refugees is just a
drop in the bucket compared to the
streams of refugees we could have from
rising seas many more coastal
communities may soon face a stark choice
spend resources defending what's already
there or spend them moving away from the
ocean Hannah Thomas Peter Sky News in
New Jersey